et puis surtout le point extrêmement
positif et j'en ai pas encore parlé
c'est la batterie 7300 milliampères
heures bienvenue dans la maison de
carton ça je vous dis pas je vous cite
là on en parle dans quelques jours il
donne un indice une pauvre dans quelques
jours j'en dis pas plus aujourd'hui on
va parler de tout autre chose on va
parler de la samsung galaxy tab escale
parce que ça ne sourit a eu l'audace je
sais pas si c'est l'audace le courage
l'envié de sortir une tablette sous
android
c'est vrai que les tablettes c'est
quelque chose qui en ce moment marche
pas énormément
les seuls qui tire un peu leur épingle
du jeu je dirais que c'est apple avec
les ipad
d'ailleurs eu de nouvel ipad cette année
il y à aussi microsoft sortirait pas
très très longtemps c'est pas vraiment
une tablette en espèce d'hybride
c'est la surface go qui vient compléter
la gamme surface via la surface qu il ya
pas mal de produits et là effectivement
samsung a sorti une nouvelle tablette la
samsung galaxy tab à 4
je suis vraiment curieux l'attesté parce
que je veux vraiment voir de quelle
manière ils sont positionnés par rapport
à ce produit parce que ça me saoule sait
très bien que de toute façon les
tablettes
c'est pas ce qui marche le mieux les
tablettes sous android c'est encore
moins ce qui marche le mieux
ils ont forcément dû mettre des
innovations d'ailleurs pas d'escale pour
vraiment redynamiser ce marché et être
sûrs de pouvoir la vendre
donc ce que je propose c'est l'ouvrir de
la tester donc investi intérieur ce
qu'on peut faire ce qui marche qui
marchent pas point positif point
négative est-ce qu'il faut l'acheter à
qui elle s'adresse enfin tout ça tout ça
j'aime beaucoup
point très positif on a le style et qui
a triché
on a ici un guide de prise en main de
démarrage un secteur charger
la recharge rapide c'est plutôt cool on
à l'usb type c usb des écoutes
voyons voir maintenant la bête en elle
même et on devine à travers sais pas si
vous le voyez leçon médina kg ha kg a
été racheté par samsung n'y a pas très
longtemps
du coup ça leur permet d'avoir vraiment
une partie audio top voilà ça c'est la
tablette samsung galaxy tab est quatre
d'un point de vue esthétique elle est
hyper simple très sobre voyez si vous
avez une seule caméra à l'arrière avec
un flash led son côté vous avez des
boutons de volume et le bouton pour
l'allumer pour l'éteindre recharge haut
parleurs prise jack
ici une connectique pour brancher le
clavier les parties est montée qui a dit
que j'ai pas là et ici haut parleurs
également pour avoir des haut parleurs
stéréo
c'est vrai quand on la regarde comme ça
au premier coup d'oeil on a l'impression
d'avoir à une énorme galaxy note 9 dans
la main ça déverrouille extrêmement bien
chaud sans marteau très bien la
reconnaissance intelligente qui couple
votre visage au scanner de l'iris
ça marche très très bien ce que je
pourrais reprocher tout de suite ses
parents reprochent alors qu'à peine
bruit pas positif c'est que tout comme
sur une galaxy note 89
j'aurais bien aimé qu'il ya un petit
rangement pour le style et j'ai trouvé
ça intéressant alors est ce que c'est
une déformation parce que j'ai
l'habitude de la note 9 ou de la note 8
je me dis voilà ça aurait été cool de
pouvoir prendre étrangers - aspen
de notre côté ce que je comprends aussi
de la part de samsung dont je relativise
franchement c'est que vu l'épaisseur du
spn vu l'épaisseur de la tablette
ça me paraît compliqué de venir logique
dans néanmoins son refus être cool bon
ça c'est pas très grave
le s pen est assez grand tiens
maintenant la main assez léger très
léger
la tablette est bien c'est pareil le
foreman pareil vraiment bien c'est pas
un truc qui est trop énorme c'est plutôt
un format qui est assez compact les
bords sont pas trop énorme tas compare
un ipad alors c'est pas un ipad 2 cette
année son ipad de l'année dernière elle
est un peu plus fine que ce type' al il
faut savoir aussi que les bords sont
forcément aussi un peu plus fin la table
ce qu'a fait un peu plus grande surtout
l'écran utile est beaucoup plus grand 5
d'un point de vue purement esthétique
est un vrai avantage là des cadres qui
sont un peu plus fin dans les caves sont
assez imposant comme n'y a pas de bouton
home forcément on le ressent
ça fait quelques bonnes heures je suis
dessus maintenant et je vais vous dire
ce que j'aime ce que j'aime pas déjà ce
que j'aime c'est le design de envers je
la trouve très classe très cohérente
problème maintenant effectivement fautes
dures envers ce sont les traces de
doigts ça vous pouvez pas est coupée
néanmoins masse que je vous conseille
vraiment de faire si vous achetez ce
produit là c'est comme une pie père
cadeau en coûte 699 euros en version 64
giga standard et si vous la voulez en
version 4g elle coûte 759 euros
c'est forcément tout de suite plus cher
moi ce que je vous conseille c'est quand
même un investissement avec c'est de
prendre le clavier qui de cover qui va
coûter 149 euros ça vous permet de
transformer votre talent et ce quatre en
ordinateur c'est plutôt pas mal un petit
peu comme tout peut retrouver avec une
surface go c'est vraiment bien d'autant
plus qu'avec un adaptateur usb tilt
c'est hdmi vous brancher à un moniteur
et votre tablette devient un ordinateur
en mode d'aix et ça c'est vraiment top
à mon avis et la voir quand tablettes à
ce prix là c'est bien c'est une belle
bécane le détailler mais on se limite
beaucoup pour aller plus loin il faut la
voir avec le clavier alors ce que j'aime
au delà de ça c'est vraiment déjà
l'écran on connaît les écrans de samsung
les écrans oled ont une qualité
extraordinaire c'est un écran super
amoled avec une définition de 2560 par
1600 pixels 10,5 pouces de diagonale
format 16/10 format un peu à part 16/10
mais je trouve vraiment vraiment très
très bien réussi la résolution c'est
d'une 287 p p puis surtout elle occupe
79% de la face avant les bords sont très
fins ça vous permet de loger ici une
petite caméra
il n'y a absolument pas de bouton pour
la verrouiller donc pour moi c'est
vraiment une belle réussite
ça c'est le premier fonds que j'adore et
deuxième fois que j'adore qui pour moi
est vraiment une très grande réussite
sur cette année ce 4 sél audio ils ont
équipé sur cette galaxy tab s4 de pas
moins de quatre haut parleurs 1 2 3 4
le son dance adaptée en fonction de la
position dans laquelle vous tenez et la
qualité elle est juste ouvrant plus
avoir beaucoup de son le son est hyper
qualitatif
il supporte le dolby atmos vous avez
vraiment une sensation d'immersion quand
vous allez regarder des vidéos quand
vous allez jouer alors on n'est pas
comme si on avait un casque avec un son
complètement hyperspécialisés on n'est
pas immersif à ce point mais lorsque
vous tenez votre tablette que vous
regardez une vidéo que vous jouez un jeu
c'est juste énorme la qualité la leçon
et là ça fait vraiment le job c'est
hyper bien répartis et je trouve que là
dessus cette tablette 4 elle est
vraiment top piscine pour vos rencontres
de la qualité du son et de l'écran je
vous mets ma vidéo du hellfest mois le
tout début vous allez voir ça envoie du
bois
il ya la qualité et en plus il ya des
volumes en plus d'avoir un excellent son
lorsque vous le branchez comme ça
lorsque je branche mon casque il ya
vachement son nom n'écoutait pas trop
fort je dis une fois de plus mais en
plus de ça la qualité elle est juste
incroyable les basses les aigus c'est là
incroyable c'est juste une des
meilleures qualités que lui en tout cas
à écouter sur ce genre d'écart c'est là
où on voit vraiment la maîtrise des
technos fait par samsung
parce que vous avez un spectre qui est
hyper large que ce soit dans les basses
vous avez des bases des graves des
graves qui sont vraiment très beaux des
aigus qui sont là vous n'êtes pas sur un
truc trop flatteur mais non c'est juste
énorme
côté photo vidéo pas passé assez
rapidement à l'avant vous avez une
caméra de 8 mégapixels avec la détection
des visages vous pouvez filmer à l'avant
en full hd
si vous voulez filmé à l'arrière vous
allez pouvoir monter jusqu en nuage des
3840 x 2160 à l'arrière vous avez une
caméra de 13 mégapixels sur votre
appareil vous avez plusieurs détection
des visages vous avez les autocollants
donc on peut jouer un petit peu en
réalité augmentée voilà pour se marier à
la fin les petits chiens chiens les
petits lapins tous les trucs un peu fous
fous on peut les faires astrig au bond
où ça marche on va pas se plaindre pour
les selles fille mise au point cette
fille c'est le fit panorama ya pas mal
de trucs et si vous allez sur la caméra
arrière alors vous avez le mode
automatique le mode beauté le mode pro
panorama hdr bon je vous passe a très
rapidement parce que très clairement on
n'est pas du tout sûr un photophone on
est néanmoins sur une vraie belle
maîtrise pas pour aller contre les
points de la part de samsung
je suis très très proches galère un peu
mais c'est normal h extrêmement proches
le pont arrière il là le point devant
hop il le fait c'est très réactif ça
marche bien j'ai rien du tout à lui
reprocher voyez on peut changer sur le
mode beauty faille la couleur de la peau
on peut régler sa bombe à ça moi j'aime
pas trop mais elle inquiète bien on a un
côté hyper l'aps là je me mets sur la
caméra arrière le rendu est plutôt cool
seuils de bien me lire trouve qu'elle
est stabilisé vous serez pas déçus
derrière
vrai savoir faire qui est maîtrisée par
samsung ça c'est plutôt cool et à
l'avant aussi en mode selphy ça
fonctionne bien
le rendu et nous voilà on n'est pas sur
un truc de dingue hall avant mais je
vous le dis de pour faire des photos des
vidéos pour faire des souvenirs
le courant côté productivité travail ça
marche très bien
quand on m'a acheté une tablette comme
la galaxy tab s4 on va pas l'acheter
pour aller faire des photos allaient
faire des vidéos par contre là où ça
peut être bien effectivement c'est
lorsque vous travaillez parce que cet
outil au final il s'adresse à plusieurs
personnes
on n'est pas sur un produit pas très
cher on est sur un produit qui coûte aux
rennes allait quasiment 700 euros si
vous voulez un ordinateur vous passer au
dessus des 800 euros tout de suite c'est
un investissement d'autant plus qu'il
faut savoir qu'à ce prix là vous avez
des ordinateurs qui font parfaitement
bien la faire donc au final à qui se
destine cette galaxy tab et scan alors
pour moi je vois deux grands types de
deux grands profils de personnes
la toute première c'est le professionnel
a besoin d'abord un outil avec vous avec
de la prise de notes avec un tableur
avec des choses comme ça vous êtes vous
de faire des photos lorsque vous
déplacer pour un assureur sont des
sinistres des choses comme ça vous
pouvez le faire
c'est un outil qui est hyper hyper hyper
hyper flexible et puis surtout le point
extrêmement positif et j'en ai pas
encore parlé c'est la batterie 7300
millan paire eur ça fait quelques heures
j'utilise que je laisse coi un peu je la
prends je mets les choses je t'ai je
regarde des vidéos pas mal de choses et
elles devront absolument pas l'autonomie
est complètement hallucinante et pouvoir
la garder plusieurs jours sans la
changer et ça c'est juste aux piscines
après le deuxième cas de figure que soit
cette tablette c'est un petit peu pour
remplacer un ordinateur dans des foyers
qui n'ont pas forcément d'un ordinateur
qui veulent un outil pratique
je prends l'exemple vous êtes une
famille un jeune couple une famille avec
enfants peu importe vous n'avez pas
forcément besoin d'acheter un ordinateur
vous voulez pas avoir un ordinateur avec
votre clavier d'ordinateur portable
voulez pas vous embêter avec ça vous
vous dites
au lieu de ça je vais acheter une galaxy
tab à 4 je vais prendre le clavier je
peux donc la pause et en mode ordinateur
fermons traitement de texte mais email
ma petite compte pas si je le veux des
tableurs excel écrire des mails à des
copains ici et ça je peux le faire en
mode ordinateur maintenant j'ai plus
envie d'embêter le soir je me mets
dedans
j'ai regardé une série ou que sais-je
encore aller sur les réseaux sociaux ou
les phares des petites photos à
l'extérieur un peu rigolote je l'enlève
du soap je la prends je pars avec les
choses que je et c'est en ça que ce
produit hyper flexible et très pratique
alors maintenant à qui se destine un
petit peu moins je dirais un petit peu
moins aux étudiants je sais pas si vous
alliez d'accord avec moi des rediffs le
mois en bas en commentaire parce que non
pas pour des questions d'utilisation
parce que très clairement des étudiants
peuvent avoir besoin de ce produit
lorsque vous êtes en cours dans des
amphis que vous prenez des notes vous
allez c'est franchement c'est top
elle marche très bien l'autonomie est
parfaite on bosse et j'ai rien à lui
reprocher par contre le prix peut être
un petit peu rédhibitoire lorsque vous
le premier que clavier plus de 800 euros
c'est cher c'est chiant quand on est
étudiant
c'est très cher et ça plaît franchement
être un frein donc pour moi cette
tablette
elle s'adresse à ceux qui peuvent la
payer à ceux qui ont en tout cas les
moyens de se l'offrir parce que ça reste
quand même un joli joujou à un prix qui
n'est pas non plus
le moins cher possible par contre
derrière vous avez un truc que je trouve
très bien fait très bien fini et
l'extrême en bonne qualité là
typiquement certains jeux comme pib j'ai
tout de suite ça vous propose une
qualité graphique est élevé il faut dire
qu'on tourne quand même souvent un
exynos 8 1895 en europe enfin sa
dragonne 835 aux états unis on a
derrière 4 gigas de ram ça marche bien
donc là on peut se faire plaisir je
trouve que vraiment en termes de
sensations lorsque vous jouez un jeu sur
un écran de cette taille c'est vraiment
vraiment vraiment été impeccable ça
change un peu des écrans des smartphones
qui vont être beaucoup plus petit là
j'ai une vision qui est vachement plus
grande
j'adore ça ça vraiment très très très
bien auprès du point de vue de l' os
c'est relativement standard vous avez un
androïde 8.1 votre tiroir d'appli sur le
bas vous pouvez naviguer et lorsque vous
prenez le style et à la main c'est là où
ça devient sympa ça vous ouvre ici votre
petite partie avec toujours à courcy
sélection intelligente capture message
animé traduction p 9
l'utilisation du spn là dessus est aussi
très très intuitif on vient de le voir
du point de vue de l'écran et du point
de vue l'audio ça marche extrêmement
bien les os fonctionne très bien coté
soc ça marche aussi très très bien la
photo et la vidéo font la sphère ya
tablettes et hop le s pen marche bien
alors justement est-ce qu'il faut
l'acheter et si oui pourquoi il faut
l'acheter si vous avez une des maximes
note
note 8 note 9 je suis pas sûr qu'il
faille acheter parce que vous avez déjà
un stylet vous avez déjà un grand écran
c'est pas le même écran c'est pas un
écran de 10 pouces mais vous avez déjà
une grande bécane cet outil se destine à
ceux qui n'ont pas de tablette à la
maison qui veulent un hybride tablettes
ordinateurs qui ne veulent pas cherché à
s'embêter à avoir un ordinateur
si vous avez déjà un ordinateur portable
à la maison et si vous avez un
smartphone récent sont pas
particulièrement l'intérêt d'aller
investir parce que c'est un
investissement qui quand même de
l'argent d'aller investir dans un projet
comme celui là après à côté de ça je
trouve que par rapport au prix d'un
samsung galaxy s 9 s9 plus work
allemande à 99
je trouve que c'est pas particulièrement
cher pour voir toutes les techniques ont
à l'intérieur après on est un petit peu
déformé et parce qu'on a l'habitude que
les smartphones haut de gamme coûte tout
de suite très cher bon coin vous annonce
un smartphone à 850 900 ou
euros c'est beaucoup d'argent mais
néanmoins ça nous surprend beaucoup
moins quand j'annonce une tablette à 700
800 euros tout rond dit waouh mais c'est
super cher s'est jamais qu'une tablette
oui mais faut pas oublier qu'en termes
de processeurs en termes de techno en
termes de caméras d'écran on a
sensiblement la même chose donc c'est
normal qu'une tablette coûte aussi cher
après c'est vrai qu'après avoir des
tarifs raiman tirés vers le bas avec la
tablette sortie par la paix cette année
l'ipad 9,7 pouces ont duré plus quoi pas
où tu habites dans tour des 400 euros ça
paraît pas déconner quand on arrive avec
une tablette à 700 euros on dit c'est
quoi c'est beaucoup plus cher
est-ce qu'il vaut son prix alors oui
très clairement il vaut son prix
est-ce qu'il faut l'acheter ça dépend
d'où ça dépend si vous avez un grand
smartphone avec un grand écran si vous
avez un smartphone récent et si vous
avez un ordinateur portable
je suis pas sûr qu'il faille aller
acheter une tablette en plus parce que
cet outil là il ya vraiment se
positionner entre un smartphone récent
et un ordinateur portable récent
également si vous n'avez pas d'ordi
portable cette bécane viendra trouver
très facilement sa place dans votre
foyer pour un petit peu de bureautique
et puis tout le reste pour sir plaisir
si vous voulez utiliser et à usage
professionnel je trouve que c'est un
très bon outil mais vous faut le clavier
avec la voir comme ça et avec le stylet
à côté je trouve qu'il lui manque un peu
quelque chose un petit peu dommage mon
plusieurs d'un côté ça aurait été bien
que samsung propose avec le clavier
directement inclus mais je me suis posé
la même question nos jours avec la
surface comme microsoft
d'un autre côté si quelqu'un veut
uniquement la tablette pourquoi aller
l'acheter que clavier obligatoirement
avec ça fait monter les prix
ce serait un petit peu rédhibitoire là
pour le coup qui prouve que c'est un bon
accessoire
si vous voulez une tablette sur android
pour relancer dynamiser marché vous
pouvez aller sur la galaxy tab s-400
aucun problème d'ailleurs vous dites moi
ce que vous en pensez
est-ce que vous pensez que samsung a
bien fait de sortir cette table et ce
quatre est ce que vous pourriez vous
vous laisser tenter et comment vous la
trouvez par rapport à la surface gold
microsoft en trop et de dix mois dans
lequel votre coeur balance voilà vous
marquez tout ça en bas on en discute on
reste connectés parce que vous allez
voir des produits technologiques super
coup comme ça on va en tester plein donc
je vous invite à faire une seule chose
c'est à vous abonner
et à rester connectés
[Musique]